>>> WE'LL HAVE MORON THE NEW
YORK CITY SUBWAY ATTK IN A
MENT.
FIRST, THE LATEST ON THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY FOR THE
FIRST TIME CALLED THE ATROCITIES
COMMITTED AGAINST UKRAINIANS
GENOCIDE.
HE SAID IT ONCE IN A SPEECH AND
A SHORT TIME AGO WITH REPORTERS
HE EXPANDED ON WHAT HE MEANT.
>> MR. PRED, HAVE YOU SEEN
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO DECLARE
GENOCIDE IN UKRAINE, SIR?
>> YES.
I CALLED IT GENOCIDE BECAUSE IT
BECOMES CLEARER AND CLEARER THAT
PUTIN IS JUST TRYING TO WIPE OUT
THE IDEA OF EVEN BEING ABLE TO
BE A UKRAINIAN.
AND THE EVIDENCE IS MOUNTING.
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN IT WAS LAST
WEEK.
THE MORE EVIDENCE IS COMING OUT
OF LITERALLY THE HORRIBLE THINGS
THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE DONE IN
UKRAINE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO ONLY LEARN
MORE AND MORE ABOUT THE
DEVASTATION.
AND WE'LL LET THE LAWYERS DECIDE
INTERNATIONALLY WHETHER OR NOT
IT QUALIFIES, BUT IT SURE SEEMS
THAT WAY TO ME.
>> AFTERWARDS, PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY OF UKRAINE THANKED
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THESE COMMENTS COME AFTER A
FIERCE DAY OF BATTLE IN THE
SOUTH AND EAST, AND AFTER
VLADIMIR PUTIN SAID THE PEACE
TALKS HAD HIT, QUOTE, A DEAD
END.
THEY ALSO CAME AFTER ZELENSKYY
SAID RUSSIANS HAD LEFT BEHIND
THOUSANDS OF MINES, SOMETHING HE
CALLED A WAR CRIME.
WE'RE IN UKRAINE'S SECOND
LARGEST CITY WITH MORE.
>> THIS IS THE CENTRAL MARKET
AREA IN KHARKIV, AND THIS IS THE
SITE OF MOST OF LAST NIGHT'S
STRIKES.
WE HAVE COME HERE WITH EMERGENCY
SERVICE FIRST RESPONDERS BECAUSE
THE RUSSIANS HAVE COME UP WITH A
NEW TACTIC.
TO INSURE THAT THE DEVASTATION
OF THEIR ATTACKS LAST FAR BEYOND
FIRST IMPACT.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL IS THE HEAD
OF THE BOMB DISPOSAL TEAM.
>> Translator: THE MINES EXPLODE
BY THEMSELVES AND CAUSE DAMAGE.
THESE ELEMENTS CAN DETONATE
BETWEEN THREE AND 40 HOURS
LATER, SO WE HAVE TO DETONATE
THEM REMOTELY TO AVOID DAMAGE TO
THE CIVILIAN POPULATION.
>> THERE ARE UNEXPLODED MINES
ALL OVER THIS AREA, SO THEY
CAN'T GET TOO CLOSE.
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY WRAP
PLASTIC EXPLOSIVES AROUND A
WIRE, LINK IT TO A DETONATOR.
THAT'S THEN PLACED NEXT TO THE
UNEXPLODED ORDINANCE.
THEY RETREAT, THEN THEY BLOW IT
UP.
A BRUTAL NEW TACTIC LEAVING
DEATH TO LIE IN WAIT FOR
UNSUSPECTING CIVILIANS.
NIMA ELBAGIR, CCNN, KHARKIV.
>> JOINING US IS CLARISSA WARD.
WE SAW THAT MINES HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND IN KHARKIV.
WHAT DID YOU SEE WHEN YOU LEFT
KYIV EARLIER TODAY?
>> WELL, I THINK WE SHOULD BE
CLEAR THAT MINES ARE BEING USED
BY BOTH SIDES, DIFFERENT KINDS
OF MINES.
THE UKRAINIANS, OF COURSE, HAVE
BEEN USING ANTI-TANK MINES.
THAT'S TO TRY TO PREVENT RUSSIAN
TANKS FROM PUSHING DEEP INTO
UKRAINIAN CITIES.
WE SAW EVIDENCE OF THAT DRIVING
ALONG TODAY.
A FIELD WAS COMPLETELY CORDONED
OFF.
THERE WERE SIGNS EVERYWHERE
SAYING MINES, AND WE SAW AN
ANTI-TANK MINE BY THE SIDE OF A
UKRAINIAN CHECKPOINT.
IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY WHEN YOU
PUSH UP NORTH FROM KYIV TO A
REGION WHERE WE HAD SPENT A
COUPLE DAYS TOWARD THE END OF
LAST WEEK.
THERE, THERE IS A VERY REAL
THREAT OF THESE ANTI-PERSONNEL
MINES THAT RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE
LEFT BEHIND.
THOSE ARE MUCH MORE DANGEROUS IN
A SENSE BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
TRIGGERED SIMPLY BY SOMEONE
WALKING OVER THEM OR WALKING
NEAR THEM.
THEY CAN, OF COURSE, CAUSE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE.
THEY HAVE ALSO LEFT ANTI-TANK
MINES THERE.
AND THIS IS A BIG PART OF WHAT
IS MAKING IT SO DIFFICULT, JOHN,
FOR UKRAINIAN FORCES TO GET INTO
ALL OF THESE AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN CUT OFF, ESSENTIALLY, FOR
WEEKS AND WEEKS ON END WHILE
THEY WERE UNDER RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION.
SOME OF THESE ROADS ARE STILL
IMPASSABLE.
OF COURSE, MANY OF THE BRIDGES
WERE ALSO BLOWN UP.
PRIMARILY BY UKRAINIAN FORCES
AGAIN TO STOP THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY FROM PUSHING IN TO CITY
CENTERS.
BUT ALL OF IT MEANING THAT EVEN
AFTER RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE LEFT,
THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF DANGERS
TO CONTEND WITH ON THE GROUND IN
TERMS OF UNEXPLODED ORDINANCE,
JOHN.
>> I SPOKE TO A 15-YEAR-OLD BOY
WHO LOST HIS MOTHER TO A MINE.
SUCH A DANGER.
RUSSIAN TROOPS DO APPEAR TO BE
GATHERING IN THE DONBAS REGION,
AND PUTIN SAID TODAY THAT TALKS
WITH UKRAINE HIT A, QUOTE, DEAD
END.
WHAT IS EXPECTED TO HAPPEN IN
THE COMING DAYS?
>> WELL, ONE REGIONAL MILITARY
OFFICIAL HERE, JOHN, HAS SAID
THEY BELIEVE THIS OFFENSIVE
COULD REALLY START ANYTIME NOW.
TOMORROW, IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
THEY ARE SEEING A STEADY BUILDUP
OF HEAVY RUSSIAN EQUIPMENT BEING
PULLED TOWARDS THE FRONT LINE.
NOW, THE ONE THING THIS OFFICIAL
SAID THAT MIGHT SORT OF WORK IN
UKRAINE'S FAVOR IS THAT THERE
ARE HEAVY RAINS FORECAST FOR THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
WITH THOSE HEAVY RAINS, IT'S
MORE LIKELY THAT RUSSIAN TANKS
IN THE EVENT THAT THEY DO START
THIS OFFENSIVE IN EARNEST WOULD
BE FORCED TO USE THE ROADS AS
OPPOSED TO THE FIELDS.
IF THEY USE THE ROADS, OF
COURSE, IT'S MUCH EASIER FOR
UKRAINIAN FORCES TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES, USING ANTI-TANK
MISSILES LIKE THE JAVELINS THAT
THE U.S. HAS BEEN PROVIDING.
IN THE MEANTIME, THOUGH, JOHN,
AS PEOPLE HERE WAIT FOR THIS
OFFENSIVE TO BEGIN, I SHOULD BE
CLEAR.
THERE IS CONSTANT SHELLING
TAKING PLACE IN THESE FRONT LINE
TOWNS, PARTICULARLY IN THE
LUHANSK REGION, AUTHORITIES
THERE WARNING THAT THEY ARE
RUNNING OUT OF SPACES IN THE
MORGUES, THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ELECTRICITY.
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
CREATE NEW CEMETERIES BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T REACH THE TRADITIONAL
CEMETERIES WHERE THEY'RE
BASICALLY USING BACKHOES TO DIG
TRENCHES AND THEN PUT THE BODIES
IN THERE, AT LEAST TEMPORARILY,
SO THAT THEY CAN BE BURIED.
IT'S A VERY SERIOUS SITUATION
ALREADY.
AND THE FEAR IS THAT THINGS ARE
GOING TO GET A LOT WORSE VERY